esta semana dio inicio el mes sagrado de
los musulmanes pero no todos los fieles
podrán festejar el ramadán como manda su
tradición debido a las guerras las
crisis económicas o la pandemia de kobe
19 calaf al samara vive en una tienda de
campaña junto a su esposa y sus cinco
hijos en el clip en el noroeste de síria
país devastado por más de 10 años de
conflicto en su recuerdo esta otra época
donde la ruptura del ayuno era una
fiesta
matt maloney a la mujer triste después
de nuestra llegada aquí al campamento de
alta en la red luis rain el ramadán para
mí se volvió sombrío y en faltan muchas
cosas estoy triste por no poder
satisfacer las necesidades básicas de
mis hijos pan comida ropa y otras cosas
porque estoy desempleado y eso supone
una gran diferencia
alamán siria cuenta con más de 67
millones de desplazados internos debido
a la guerra civil en este campamento
muchos podrán ahora disfrutar la comida
del iftar gracias a la ayuda de los
voluntarios
la comida consiste en 900 gramos de
arroz un muslo de pollo yogur dátiles
una manzana y una barra de pan se
distribuye entre los desplazados que
viven en estos campos durante este mes
porque no tienen nada que comer para
alistar con la esperanza de que el
ramadán sea mejor para dejar huella
en afganistán nación asolada por casi 40
años de guerra mientras eeuu anunció la
retirada total de sus tropas
los musulmanes volvieron a las mezquitas
para rezar el taragüí lejos queda la
desolación de los templos debido al
coronavirus desde a la baja incidencia
de los contagios las autoridades piden
respetar las medidas de bioseguridad la
solución de esta enfermedad es que todo
el mundo tenga mucho cuidado en las
reuniones en la oración del viernes en
los rezos grupales y también en las
reuniones políticas sociales culturales
y religiosas más de 1800 millones de
musulmanes celebran el ramadán en todo
el mundo si en las restricciones por el
kobe 19 son más ligeras este año miles
de familias volverán a festejarlo con un
sabor amargo